in all honesty last year
i had like my book had just come out and
i think i'd been like on a plane train
or automobile like every day for
like a really long time and so i had
said to my family like
i love everyone so much i'm gonna just
stay
home for like i'm gonna facetime but
the four cats and i just need to be home
are in
and so it was a gorgeous healthy
boundary and so it's
kind of going to look like that again
except for this year it's because of
pandemic
not because i have been so busy so i
would have gone home to say alright
everybody but this year it's just more
like we're pandemic chilling
you know still not mingling my mom who i
love
so much she is someone who is a stunning
cancer survivor and she
just has like a few other little baby
predispositions to
the to covid that you know we're just
not really
mingling right now because she's high
risk and and we're just you know
got to keep mama safe so i'm that's kind
of part of it too
i do know that like from everything that
i know
we are absolutely coming back and it
seems like 2021
will be when we do i just have to i mean
we love
who we get to work with and we obviously
want to keep everyone really safe
and i also think that i mean
everyone doesn't want to be able to do
like less for our people
because of not being able to have
like access to like to the stuff
and so and i just can't imagine like
bobby not
being able to live his best life doing
his renovations the way he needs to do
it
and he's so good at it like gosh you
feel good i do miss seeing renovations
every week that was so cool i miss them
but anyway yeah we go back in 2021 do i
separation anxiety
yes do i facetime 10 16 times a week yes
does he still answer less than four
percent of the time yes
um is that because like he's not he
doesn't love me as much
no i just think i facetime him so much
more than most people facetime someone
because i love tammy can't help it